The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we've been
developing the procedure
to describe a quantum gas
of identical particles.
That's our non-interacting.
So what does that mean?
Is that we are thinking
about the Hamiltonian
for a system of N particles.
If they are not
interacting, it can
be written as the sum
of the contributions
for the individual particles.
And if they are
identical, it's basically
the same particle
for each one of them.
Same Hamiltonian for
each one of them.
OK?
How do we handle these?
Well, if you regard this
as a quantum problem,
for a single particle--
so for each one
of these Hamiltonians-- we
can find the eigenstates.
So there's a bunch of states
that say label by k because we
are ultimately have in
mind the plane waves that
describe gas particles in a box.
And there is corresponding
energy levels
for the single
particles, epsilon k.
And the single particle
spectrum can therefore
can be described by a bunch
of energies, a lot of energy
levels, with
different values of k
and different allowed
discretized energies.
Now, when we want to describe
a case of N particles
that are
non-interacting, we said
that we could, in
principle, pick one k here,
one k here, one k here.
And if we are
dealing with bosons,
potentially more than
one at each side.
And so the state would
then be described
by a bunch of
occupation numbers Nk.
And this Nk will be 0 or 1 if
you are talking about fermions,
but any integer if you
are talking about bosons.
So this eta being
plus or minus was
used to distinguish
appropriate symmetrization
or anti-symmetrization.
Now, once we have a
state such as this,
clearly the N
particle hamintonium
acting on a state
that is symmetrized
with these bunch of
occupation numbers
will give us back this state.
The energy that we
would be getting
is summing over all
possible k values, epsilon k
times the number of occurrance
of that in this state.
Again, multiplying
this state back.
Of course, we have a constraint
that the number of particles
matches the sum of the
occupation numbers.
So then we said,
OK, this is just
a description of the state
that they want to describe,
or the set of states
that represent
this system of identical
non-interacting partners
in quantum mechanics.
So the next stage, we want to
do some kind of first statistics
for them.
And we had seen that
basically, in order
to assign appropriate statistics
in case of quantum systems,
we have to deal with
a density matrix.
And we saw that in the
canonical representation,
the density matrix
is complicated
and amounts to some kind of
interaction among particles.
Although there is no
interaction at this level,
the symmetrization or
anti-symmetrization
create states that are
intermixed in a manner that
appears as if you
have an interaction.
We found that, however,
we could get rid of that
by going to the grand canonical
ensemble where we would trade
in the constraint that
the number of particles
is fixed with a
chemical potential.
And in this ensemble, we
found that the density matrix
is diagonal in this
representation.
So the diagonal
elements can be thought
of as the probability of one of
these occupation number sets.
And so the probability of a
particular set of occupations
in this grand
canonical prescription
is proportional to e
to the beta-- of course
we have mu if we are going to
this grand canonical ensemble--
minus epsilon k,
and then we had Nk.
So the probability that
a particular one of these
is occupied Nk times in this
grand canonical prescription
is simply an exponential.
And of course, the
different k levels
are completely
independent of each other.
So the probability factor
arises in this fashion.
Of course, as any probability,
we have to normalize this.
Normalization is appropriate.
We call the grand canonical
partition function
and will be different
whether we are dealing
with boson statistics
or fermion statistics.
Actually, because we have
a structure such as this,
Q is going to be the
product of the normalization
of each individual one.
And therefore, log
of Q is going to be
a sum of the
contributions that I
would get for the normalization
of each individual ones.
And of course, the log
of whatever normalization
I have for the individual one.
If I have the case of a fermions
where Nk gets 0 or 1 as the two
possibilities, then
the normalization
will be simply 1 plus
this exponential.
And I choose to write that
as z e to the minus beta
epsilon of k where
I have introduced z
to be e to the beta mu.
Because this combination
occurs all the time,
I don't want to
keep repeating that.
So this was for the
case of fermions.
For the case of bosons where
N goes 0, 1, 2, 3, et cetera,
this is a geometric series.
For the geometric
series, when I sum it,
I would get 1 over this factor.
So when I take the log I
will have a minus sign here.
And I can put the
Boson and Fermi cases
together by simply putting
a factor of minus eta
here so that I have the plus
for the case of fermions
and the minus for
the case of bosons.
OK?
So this is one thing
that we will be using.
The other thing is that
this is the probability
for this level having a
certain occupation number.
In k we can always ask,
what is the average of Nk?
And from this probability it is
easy to calculate the average.
And the answer, again,
can be collapsed
into one expression for the
case of bosons and fermions
as 1 over z inverse e to the
beta epsilon of k minus eta
encompassing both
fermions and bosons.
So these results give some idea
both at the microscopic level--
in terms of occupation numbers
of these different levels--
and macroscopic level a
grand partition function
from which we can
construct thermodynamics.
Actually, full
probability, again,
in this ensemble which we
can transform in principle
and get density matrices,
et cetera, in other basis.
But these are the
kinds of things
that we can do for any
interacting Hamiltonian.
OK?
Now, what I said over
here was that I'm actually
interested in the case of a gas.
So let's again think
about the type of gas
such as the one in this
room that we are interested.
And again, to make a
contrast with something
that we may want
to do later, let's
emphasize that it is a
non-relativistic gas.
So the Hamiltonian H is
essentially free particle
in a box of volume
V, the thing that we
have been using
all the time, just
the kinetic energy of
a one particle state.
And for that we know that
the single particle energy
levels are characterized
by a vector k.
As three components, in fact.
And h bar squared
over 2mk squared.
And we've discussed what
the discretization of k
is appropriate to
the size of the box.
We won't go over that.
So again, maybe it is
important to mention
that because of the
discretizatoin of the k values,
the spacing between
possible values of k
are 2 pi over l
in each direction.
And ultimately
what we want to do
is to replace these sums over
k's in the limit of large boxes
with integrals over k.
So these go over to an
integral over k times
the density factor that you
get in going from the sum
to the integral, which is 2
pi cubed times the volume.
I will introduce one
other factor here,
which is that when we
are talking about quantum
particles and
bosons and fermions,
they are typically assigned
also another state--
another parameter-- that
characterizes their spin.
And depending on the
possible values of spin,
you will have g
copies of the system.
And this g will be related
to the quantum spin--
to the formula 2s 1-- so
that when you have fermions,
typically s is half integer and
this will be an even number.
Whereas for bosons it
will be an odd number.
So that's, again,
something that we've seen.
You just, essentially
says multiply everything
by some factor of g.
Now if I go through
this procedure
that I have outlined
here, I will ultimately
get the grand partition
function of the gas-- which
as we will see is related
to its pressure-- in terms
of the chemical potential.
Throughout the course we've seen
that the more interesting thing
to look at is how things depend
on density rather than chemical
potential.
So I'd better use this result
to get what the density is.
How do I do that?
Well, once I have determined
what the chemical potential is,
the average number
of particles will
be the sum over and the
average occupation numbers
that I have in all
of these states.
And according to the
prescription that we have over
here, in the limit of a
large box, this sum over k
becomes gV intergral d
cubed k 2 pi Q. Ultimately
I will divide by
V so I will have
the formula for the density.
And what is Nk?
Well, I have the formula for Nk.
It is 1 over z
inverse e to the beta.
Epsilon k is h bar
squared k squared over 2m,
and then I have a minus 8.
OK?
So if I divide through by V,
really I will have the density.
Get rid of this V. But I
have to do that integral.
Now for this and a
lot of other things,
you can see that always I
will have sums or integrations
over the combination that
appears in the exponent
and enhances dimension list
which is beta epsilon of k.
So let me introduce
a new variable.
Let me call x to be the
combination beta h bar squared
k squared over 2m.
So I'm going to call this
e to the x, if you like.
So I have changed
variables from k to x.
k in terms of x is simply square
root of 2m inverse of beta--
which is kt-- divided
by h bar squared.
But I took a square
root so it's just h bar.
Times x to the 1/2.
OK?
Now, I realize that h bar
is in fact h divided by 2pi.
So the 2pi I can put
in the numerator.
And then I remember that
actually the combination h
divided by square
root of 2pi mkt,
I was calling these
thermal wavelength lambda.
And k should have the dimensions
of an inverse landscape,
so that's the appropriate
thing to choose.
So what do I get?
I take a square
root of pi inside
and I'm left with 2 square root
of pi divided by this parameter
lambda x to the 1/2.
Again, for later
clarity, let's make
sure we remember
this was our lambda.
So this is the
variable k that I need.
In fact, for the--
for the integration
I have to also make
a change in dk.
So I not that dk, if I
take a derivative here,
I will get x-- 1/2x to the minus
1/2 becomes root pi over lambda
x to the minus 1/2 dx.
Actually, the factor
that I need over here
is dk-- d cubed
k over 2pi cubed.
Now everything only depends
on the magnitude of k.
So I will take advantage
of spherical symmetry,
write d cubed k as 4pi k
squared dk divided by 8pi cubed.
And then I substitute
from k squared and dk
above in terms of this x.
So I will have a 1 over 2pi
squared from this division.
k squared is simply 4pi
over lambda squared x.
This is k squared.
dk is root pi over lambda
x to the minus 1/2 dx.
So you can see lots
of things cancel out
and the answer is going
to be x to the 1/2
dx divided by lambda cubed.
And what is left from all
of these pi's et cetera,
is a factor of square
root of pi over 2.
Or 2 in the numerator or
a square root of pi over 2
in the denominator.
OK?
So if I do these set
of changes that I
have on the right
part of the board,
what do I have for density?
The density becomes simply g.
I have this integral
over k that I
have recast as an integral
that is x to the 1/2 dx.
Let me pull out the factor of
lambda cubed on the outside.
So I have g over lambda cubed.
I will pull out to that
factor of root pi over 2
that I had before.
And then I have
the integral from 0
to infinity dx x to the 1/2.
Actually, let me write
it in this fashion.
dx x to the 1/2.
And in the denominator,
what do I have?
I have z universe
into the x minus 8.
So we did all of these and
we ended up with an integral
that we don't recognize.
So what we are going to do is
to pretend that we recognize it
and give it a name.
All right?
So we define a set of functions
f sub m of variable z.
Once I do the integration over
x, I will get a function of z.
So that function of z
I will call fm of z.
But clearly I have a different
fm if I have eta minus 1 or eta
plus 1 for bosons of fermions.
So there is two
classes of things.
What's this m?
OK.
So here I had the
integral x to the 1/2.
It turns out that you will get
a whole bunch of these integrals
where the [INAUDIBLE] that
is out front in the numerator
is different.
So I will generalize this x to
the 1/2, this 1/2 to something
that I'll call it m minus 1.
And then I have z inverse
e to the x minus eta.
And if these normalized
so that what is in front
is 1 over m minus 1 factorial.
OK?
So these are very
important functions.
Everything we will
do later on we
will be expressing in
terms of these functions.
Now, clearly what is happening
here corresponds to m minus 1
being equal to 1/2
or m being 3/2.
What is this normalization?
Well, for the normalization,
if this is 1/2
I would need 1/2 factorial.
And if you go and look at
the various definitions
that we have for the gamma
function or the factorial,
you can check that 1/2
factorial is root pi over 2.
And, indeed, we saw
this already when
we wrote the expression
for the surface area
in general dimensions
that involved
factorial function
appearing as fractions.
And in order to get the
right result in two or three
dimensions, you can
check that this root
pi over 2 for 1/2
factorial is correct.
So, indeed, I already have
this root pi over 2 over here.
It was properly normalized.
So the whole thing
here can be written
as n is g over lambda
cubed f 3/2 eta of z.
That is the expression
that relates
the density to the chemical
potential or this communication
e to the beta mu, which
is z or the fugacity
is simply this nice formula.
OK?
But what we want is
to calculate something
like the pressure for the gas.
Well, let me remind you that
log Q, essentially, quite
generally, log Q comes
from normalizing something
that is like mu times the
total number of particles
minus the energy-- you can
kind of read that from here--
and then there would be TS
from the number of states.
This was the general
formula that we had.
And when we substitute for
a system that is extensive,
where E for a gas is
mu n plus TS minus PV,
we see that the log of
the partition function
is simply the
combination beta PV.
Of course, again, this
pressure as a function
of density or chemical
potential would be different
whether we are thinking
about bosons of fermions.
But it can be calculated
from the kind of sum
that we have over here.
So let's do that.
So I have beta P
which is something
like log Q divided
by V. Is obtained
by doing this sum over k
over V. And so what do I get?
I will get-- first of all,
I have the minus eta sum
over k [INAUDIBLE]
with g integral
over k divided by 2pi cubed.
The volume factor cancels
because I divided by volume.
I have log of 1 minus eta z
e to the minus beta-- again,
h bar squared k
squared over 2m--
are the energy that
I'm dealing with.
OK?
Fine.
What do we do with this?
We make the same
change of variables
that we have over
here from k to x.
So then I would have minus
eta d cubed k over 2pi cubed
gets replaced with this 2
over root pi lambda cubed.
And then I have the
integral 0 to infinity dx
x to the 1/2 log of 1 minus
eta z e to the minus x.
Huh.
It seems like-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What happened
to your factor g?
PROFESSOR: G?
Good question.
Anything else?
So I was hoping
to have integrals
that are all expressible in
terms of this-- these set
of functions that I defined.
This log does not fall
into this category.
Should I define something else?
Well, the answer
is no because I can
make that integral
look like this
by simbly doing an
integration by parts.
So we do integrate by parts
in which case what I do
is I take a derivative
of this and I
take an integral
of x to the 1/2.
Integral of x to the 1/2
becomes x to the 3/2 over 3/2.
There is, of course,
a minus sign involved.
So this minus becomes plus eta.
Make sure I have
the g this time.
2 over root pi lambda cubed.
I have the integral
from 0 to infinity dx.
x to the 1/2 became
x to the 3/2.
The 3/2 I will bring out front.
So I have 1 over 3/2 here.
And then I have to take the
derivative of this function.
What's the derivative
of the log?
It is 1 over the argument of
the log times the derivative
of the argument of
the log which is minus
eta z, the derivative
of e to the minus x,
which is e to the minus x.
And this minus becomes plus.
OK?
So let's arrange
things a little bit.
I can get rid of these etas
because eta squared will be 1.
What is the answer, therefore?
It is g over lambda cubed.
That's fine.
If root pi over 2
is 1/2 factorial,
and I multiply 1/2 factorial
with 3/2, what I will get
is 1 over 3/2 factorial.
Because n factorial is n
times n minus 1 factorial.
And then, what do I have?
I have 0 to infinity dx.
x to the 3/2, divide the
numerator and denominator by z
e to the minus x and you get z
inverse e to the x minus eta.
And lo and behold, we have
a function of the variety
that we had defined on the
board corresponding to n minus 1
being 3/2 or n being 5/2.
So what we have here is
that beta P, depending
on whatever statistics
we are dealing with,
is g over lambda
cubed f 5/2 eta of z.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what you have to
do is always ensure
what is happening to
the boundary terms.
Boundary terms will
be a product of x
to the 3/2 and this factor.
At x equals to 0, x to the 3/s
will ensure that you are 0.
At x goes to infinity,
the exponential
will ensure that you're to 0.
So the boundary
terms are important
and indeed you
have to check them.
And you can check
that they are 0.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I think the factor
that multiples x to the 3/2
is [INAUDIBLE].
But it's-- the
argument still holds.
PROFESSOR: The
argument still holds
because as x goes to infinity,
e to the minus x goes to 0.
Log of 1 is 0.
In fact, you can ask,
how does it go to 0?
It goes to 0 exponentially.
Exponentially it
will [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
Thank you for the correction.
OK?
All right.
There's one other thing
that we can take a look at.
The total energy.
OK.
So the energy in each
one of these states
is given by that formula.
So if I ask, what is the total
expectation value of energy?
And again, in
thermodynamics we expect
the extensive quantities such
as the energy should have,
in an aerodynamic sense,
well defined values
so I won't write the
expectation value.
Is going to be a sum
over k Nk epsilon k.
And this will depend on the
statistics that I'm looking at.
And what I will have is
that this will go over
to an integral over k divided
by 2pi cubed multiplied g
and multiplied by
V. I have epsilon
of k which is h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
The expectation
value of N, which
is z inverse e to the minus
beta-- sorry-- z inverse
e to the plus beta h bar squared
k squared over 2m minus 8.
OK?
So the simplest way to do this
is to first of all divide by V.
So I can define
an energy density.
Actually, since I'm
going to change variables
to this combination
that is x, I notice
that up to a factor of
betas the numerator is x.
So let me actually calculate
the combination beta e over V.
That only depends on
this combination x.
So what is it?
It is g-- the integral
over k, I know
how to replace it
with something that
involves x-- is going to give
me 2 over root pi lambda cubed.
Integral 0 to infinity dx.
From the change of variables,
I have x to the 1/2.
But I introduced
one factor of x here
because I have this energy
factor in the numerator.
So that changes this
to x to the 3/2.
And then again, I have z
inverse e to the x minus 8.
OK?
So if is one of the integrals
that we have defined.
In fact, it is exactly what I
have above for the pressure,
except that I don't have the
factor of 3/2 that appeared
nicely to give the
right normalization.
So what I conclude is
that this quantity is
in fact g over lambda cubed
times 3/2 of f 5/2 eta of z.
OK?
But they are exactly
the same functions
for energy and pressure.
So you can see
that, irrespective
of what the chemical
potential is doing,
I can state that for the quantum
system e is always 3/2 PV.
Of course, we have seen
this expression classically.
Now what happens
quantum mechanically
is that the pressure
starts to vary
in some complicated
way with density.
But what we learn is
that energy will also
vary in the same complicated
way with density,
such that always this
formula EV 3/2 PV is valid.
There is some nice
symmetry reason
for why that is the
case that you explore
in one of the problems
that you will see.
OK?
So these are the
characteristics.
In some sense we have
solved the problem
because we know both density
and pressure in terms
of chemical potential.
So all we need to do
is to invert this, get
the chemical potential
as a function of density,
insert it in the
formula for pressure
and we have pressure as
a function of density.
But since these are
kind of implicit
through these f
functions, we don't quite
know what that means.
So the next stage
is to really study
how these f functions
behave and how
we can relate their behaviors
to dependence on density.
And we will see that we have to
distinguish between low density
and high density regimes.
What does it mean?
Well, you can see that both
have players on the right hand
side is dimensionless.
The only dimension
full combination
that we have here is
N-- well, we can make it
dimensionless by multiplying
by lambda cubed over g.
So it turns out
that whether or not
you see things that are
classical or things that
are very quantum
mechanical depend
on this degeneracy factor.
Which, within our context of
statistical physics of gases,
we define to be
the communication N
lambda cubed over g.
And we will regain
classical behaviors
when degeneracy
is small, density
is small enough such that
d is much less than 1.
We will see totally
new behavior that
is appropriate to quantum
mechanics in other limit
where [? d ?] becomes large.
OK?
So this distinguishes classical
versus quantum behavior.
Now, we expect to regain
classical behavior
in the limit of
very low densities.
That's what we've
been kind of saying
from the very first lecture
that low density gas has
this ideal behavior
where PV is Nkt.
And, therefore, let's
focus on the limit
where V is much less than
1, which is classical.
And since d is f
3/2 eta of z, we
need the behavior of the
function when it is small--
and I'll show you
[INAUDIBLE] consistently
that the function is small
when it's argument is small.
So we'll see that d
less than 1 implies
or is implied by z
being less than 1.
OK?
So let's take a look at
one of these functions,
fm eta z, 1 over m
minus 1 factorial, 0
to infinity dx, x
to the m minus 1,
z universe e to the x minus 1.
And I'd like to explore the
limit of this when z is small.
So that's currently not very
good because I have z inverse.
So what I will do is I will
multiply by z e to the minus
x both numerator
and denominator.
So I will have m minus
1 factorial integral 0
to infinity dx x
to the n minus 1.
I have z e to the minus x.
I have-- oops, there
was an eta here.
1 minus eta z e to the minus x.
OK?
Then I say, well, the
thing that is appearing
in the denominator,
I can write as a sum
of a geometric series
in powers of z.
And that's, after all,
what I'm attempting to do,
make an expansion
in powers of z.
It starts with z to the minus x.
And 1 over 1 minus
eta z to the minus
x I can write as the sum alpha
going from 0 to infinity of eta
z e to the minus x raised
to the power of [INAUDIBLE].
This geometric series sums
to what I have over there.
OK?
Let's rearrange
this a little bit.
I will take the sum
over alpha outside.
Well, I notice that actually
I have here, this first term,
which is different from
this by a factor of eta.
So let me multiply by an
eta and get another eta.
And then I have a sum
that starts from 1
to infinity of eta z e to the
minus x to the power of alpha.
So I have eta z to
the power of alpha.
I have one other eta here.
And then I have the integration
over x, x to the m minus 1.
I didn't write e to the
minus x to the alpha
because I pulled it
out the integration.
I will write it now. e
to the minus alpha x.
And I didn't write 1
over n minus 1 factor.
Now, once more, this is an
integration that you have seen.
The result of doing
integral dx x to the m
minus 1 e to the minus x is
simply m minus 1 factorial.
Except that it is
not e to the minus
x but it's e to
the minus alpha x.
I can rescale
everything by alpha
and I will pull out a
factor of alpha to there.
OK?
So what do we have?
We have that fm eta of z
as a [? power series ?]
representation, alpha
running from 1 to infinity,
z to the alpha divided
by alpha to the m.
It's an alternating series
that starts with plus
and then becomes a
minus, et cetera.
So if I were to
explicitly write this,
you will see how nice it is.
It is z plus eta z squared
2 to the m plus z cubed 3
to the m plus eta z
to the 4 4 to the m.
And you can see why it is such a
nice thing that really deserves
to have a function
named after it.
So we call that nice
series [? to  Vf. ?]
Now, for future reference,
note the following.
If I take a derivative of
this function with respect
to z-- its argument-- then
in this power series, say,
z to the 4 becomes 4z cubed.
4 will cancel one of
the 4's that I have here
and it becomes 4
to the m minus 1.
This becomes 3 to the m minus 1.
So you can see that
the coefficients that
were powers of m become
powers of m minus 1.
Numerator has gone
down by one factor.
So let's multiply by z.
So the numerator is
now what it was before.
The denominators, rather than
being raised to the power of m,
are raised to the
power of m minus 1.
So clearly, this is the
same thing as fm minus 1.
So basically these functions
have this nice character
that they are like a ladder.
You take a derivative
of one and you
get the one that is
indexed by one less.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is there a factor
of eta that comes out to be
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In the derivatives?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it seems to
me that there's an eta-- like,
in that relation that--
PROFESSOR: In this relation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's do it by step.
If I take a
derivative, divide dz,
I get 1 plus eta z squared
z 2 to the m minus 1 plus
z squared' 3 to the m minus 1.
Then I multiply by
z, this becomes z,
this becomes z squared,
this becomes z cubed.
And you can see
that the etas are
exactly where they should be.
AUDIENCE: Would you explain
why the index of summation
starts from--
PROFESSOR: One?
AUDIENCE: --one.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's take a look
at this function.
You can see there is a z
inverse in the denominator.
So I made it into a z here.
So you can see that if z is very
small, if will start with z.
All right?
Now what happened here?
I wrote this as a sum
of geometric series.
I pulled out this factor of
z that was in the numerator,
and the denominator I wrote as
a series that starts with 0.
But then there is
this z out front.
I pulled this z e to the
minus x in front here
and then it starts with 1.
I could have written it--
I can put this in here
and write it as alpha
plus 1 with alpha
starting from 0, et cetera.
Or I can write it [INAUDIBLE].
Or, alternatively, you can
say, let's put the eta here
and eta here.
And then I see that this is
the geometric series where
the first term is this z
to the minus x [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
So I want to erase this
board but keep this formula.
So let me erase it
and then rewrite it.
So this I will rewrite as
N lambda q over g, which
is my degeneracy factor,
is f 3/2 eta of z.
And in the limit
where z goes to small,
I can use the expansion
that I just derived,
which is z plus eta z squared
2 to the-- what is it--
3/2 plus z cubed.
3 to the 3/2 and so forth.
You can see that precisely
because as z goes to 0,
this series goes to
0, that smallness of z
is the same thing or implied
by the smallness of z.
But that z is equal to d
only at the lowest order.
So what happens
at higher orders,
z-- inverting this-- is d minus
eta z squared 2 to the 3/2 plus
z cubed 3 to the
3/2, and so forth.
And we saw this when I
was doing the calculation
for the interacting gas, that
clearly to lowest order z
equals to d, if I want
to get the next order,
I substitute the result
of the previous order
into this expression.
So z I substitute
for d, I will d
minus eta d squared 2 to the
3/2 as the first contribution.
And then something that
is order of d cubed.
And if I want the answer
to the d cubed order,
I take this whole thing that
is that order of d squared
and substitute in this series.
And so what do I get?
I will get d minus
eta 2 to the 3/2,
square of z-- which is the
square of this quantity--
square of this quantity
is d squared minus twice
the product of these two terms.
So I have twice eta
d cubed 2 to the 3/2.
And then square of this term,
but that's order of e to the 4.
I don't care for that.
And then I have, from here,
plus d cubed 3 to the 3/2
ignoring terms of the
order of d to the 4th.
OK?
So z is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] z equals
d minus and the d [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah, great.
Thank you.
Minus.
Good.
Saves me having to go back later
when the answer doesn't match.
OK.
Fine.
Now let's organize terms.
The lowest order I have d.
At order of d
squared I have still
just this one term, minus eta
d squared over 2 to the 3/2.
We knew that was the correct
result at order of d squared.
At order of d cubed
I have two terms.
One is the product
of these two terms.
The etas disappear,
minus 2, and this
will give me 2 over
9 which is 1/4.
And from other part, I have
1 over 3 to the 3/1 d cubed.
And I haven't calculate things
at order of d to the 4th.
OK?
Fine.
So we have calculated
in a power series
that we can go to
whatever order you like.
This is z which is related
to chemical potential
as a function of
this degeneracy that
is simply related to density.
Now, the formula for the
pressure is up there.
It is that eta P is g over
lambda cubed f 5/2 eta of z.
Right?
So reorganizing
this a little bit,
the dimensionless
form is beta P lambda
cubed over g f 5/2 eta of z.
f 5/2 we can make an expansion.
It is z plus eta z squared
2 to the 5/2 plus z cubed 3
to the 5/2 and so forth.
For z I substitute
from the line above.
So I have d minus eta d squared
2 to the 3/2 plus 1/4 minus 1
over 3 to the 3/2 d cubed.
So that's the first term.
The next term is eta 2
to the 5/2 z squared.
So I have to square what is
up here and here keeping terms
to order of d cubed.
So what do I have?
I have d squared from
squaring this term.
And a term that is twice the
product of these two terms.
That's the only term
that is order of d cubed.
So I have minus 2 eta
2 to the 3/2 d cubed.
And finally, z cubed
over 3 to the 5/2
would be d cubed
over 3 to the 5/2.
And I haven't
calculated anything
at all of d to the 4th.
OK?
So what do I have?
I have that beta P
lambda cubed over g.
Well, you can see
that everything
is going to be proportional
to d d squared d cubed.
So let's put out the factor of d
which is m lambda cubed over g.
So this is just one factor
of d that I have pulled out.
So that then I start with 1,
and then the next correction
I have an eta d squared
2 to the 3/2 here,
eta d squared 2 to the 5/2
here with opposite sign.
So this is twice
bigger than that.
So the sum total of them would
be minus eta divided by 2
to the 5/2 times d
squared-- one factor
of d I have out front-- the
other factor I will write here
and lambda cubed over g.
And then at order of d cubed,
I have a bunch of terms.
I have a 1/4 here, and from
the product of these terms,
I will have etas disappear,
I have 2 divided by 2
to the 8/2 which is 2
to the 4th which is 16.
So the product of these things
will give me a minus 1/8.
I have 1/4 minus
1/8 I will get 1/8.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then we have minus
3-- 1 over 3 to the 1/2
and this 3 to the 5/2.
This is three times
larger than this.
This is 3 over 3 to the 5/2.
Subtract one of
them, I will be left
minus 2 divided by
3 to the 5/2 [? N ?]
lambda cubed over g squared.
And so forth.
So you can see that the
form that we have is beta
P-- the pressure--
starts with density.
I essentially divide it
through by lambda q over g.
I start with the
ideal gas result, n,
and then I have a correction
that is order of n squared.
I can write it as B2 n squared.
In view up our
[INAUDIBLE] co-efficients.
And we see that our B2 is
minus eta times-- sorry.
Minus eta 2 to the 5/2
times n lambda cubed over g.
Remember that B2s, et cetera,
had dimensions of volume.
So if the volume is
provided by lambda cubed,
it is an additional factor.
For fermions it's a
positive pressure.
So the pressure goes up because
fermions repel each other.
For bosons it is negative.
Bosons attract each other.
And we have actually
calculated this.
We did a calculation
of the canonical form
where we had the one
exchange corrections.
And if you go back to the
notes or if you remember,
we had calculated
precisely this.
But then I said that
if I went and tried
to calculate the
next correction using
the canonical
formulation, I would
have to keep track
of diagrams that
involve three exchanges
and all kinds of things
and it was complicated.
But in this way of
looking at things,
you can see that we can very
easily compute the [INAUDIBLE]
co-efficients and higher orders.
In particular, the
third [INAUDIBLE]
co-efficient we compute to be
1/8 minus 2 3 to the 5/2 lambda
cubed over g squared.
And you can keep
going and calculate
higher and higher
order corrections.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you're doing
this expansion for the z being
close to 0--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --it appears
that chemical potential
is a large negative number.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What
kind of interaction
does it imply between our
grand canonical and [INAUDIBLE]
and the system from
which it takes particles?
Because chemical potential
represents energy threshold
for the particle to
move from there to--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So as you say, it corresponds
to being large and negative.
Which means that,
essentially, I think
the more kind of physical way
of looking at it is-- this z
is e to the beta mu-- is
the likelihood of grabbing
and adding one particle
to your system.
And what we have is that this
is much, much less than 1.
And the way to
achieve that is to say
that it is very hard to extract
and bring in other particle
from whatever
reservoir you have.
And because it is
so hard that you
have such low density of
particles in the system
that you have.
So for example, if you are in
vacuum and you put a surface,
and some atoms from
the surface detach
and form a gas in
your container,
the energetics of
binding those atoms
to the substrate particles
was huge and few of them
managed to escape.
OK?
All right.
But this is only one limit.
And this is the limit
that we already knew.
We are really interested
in the other limit
where we are quantum dominated.
And clearly we want
to go to the limit
where the argument
here is not small.
I have to include a large
number of terms in this series.
And then I have to
figure out what happens.
I mean, how do I have
to treat the cases where
I want to solve this equation
and the left hand side, d, is
a large number?
So how can I make the value
of the function large?
What does that imply about
argument of the function?
OK?
So different functions
will become large
for different values
of the argument.
And as we will show
for the case of bosons,
these functions become large
where the argument becomes 1.
Whereas, for fermions, they
become large when the argument
itself becomes very large.
So the behavior of these
functions is very different.
When they become
large they become
large at different
points when we
are thinking about
bosons and fermions.
And because of
that, at this stage
I have to separately
address the two problems.
So up to here, the
high temperature limit,
we sort of started
from the same point
and branched off slightly by
going into boson and fermion
direction.
But when I go to
the other limit,
I have to discuss the
two cases separately.
So let's start with
the case of fermions.
So degenerate-- degenerating
a sense of d being larger
than 1 rather than
character flaws.
So what do we do in this limit?
So what I need to know is to
look at one of these functions.
So let's say d n lambda
cubed over g is f 3/2 minus
of z which is 1 over this
1/2 factorial integral 0
to infinity dx x to the 1/2.
And here I have a
plus because I'm
looking at the fermionic
version of these.
I have z inverse e to the
x and I can write that as e
to the x minus log z.
OK?
Now, essentially, if I look
at this function-- actually,
let's look at the function
that is just 1 over e
to the x minus log z plus
1 as a function of x.
What does it do in the
limit where z is large?
In the limit where z is large,
log z is also very large.
And then what I
have is something
that if x is much less
than log z-- essentially,
this factor will
be 0 and I have 1.
Whereas if x is much
greater than log z,
then this is exponentially large
quantity and I will have 0.
So basically, at
around log z, this
switches from being very
close to 0 to being 1.
Indeed, that x equals
2 log z is exactly 1/2.
So here is 1/2.
It is switching very rapidly.
And you can see
that, essentially,
the value of the function
depends on the combination
x minus log z.
So if I were to make
log z much larger,
I'm essentially transporting
this combination
without changing its shape,
either in one direction
or the other direction.
OK?
And if I go to the limit,
essentially that log z is
very large, I will have 1
for a huge distance and then,
at some point, I
would switch to 0.
And what I'm doing, therefore,
is to essentially approximately
integrating from 0 to
log z x to the 1/2 dx.
Which would give me x to the
3/2-- sorry, log z to the 3/2
over 3/2.
And you can see
that I can repeat
this for any other
value of m here.
I would be integrating
x to the m minus 1.
So you would conclude that the
limit as z is much, much larger
than 1, of one of these
functions fm minus of z,
is obtained by integrating
0 to log z dx x to the m.
I will get another
factor of log z.
And then I will get
log z to the power
of m divided by 1
over m multiplying
by 1 over m minus 1 factorial.
It will give me m factorial.
Now, of course there will
be correction to this
because this function
would be equal to this
if I was integrating
a step function.
And I don't have
I have something that
gradually vanishes.
Although, the interval
over which it vanishes
is scaling much
smaller than log z.
So what you can do, is you
can do some manipulations
and calculate corrections
to this formula that
become significant as log
z is not exactly infinite
but becomes smaller and smaller.
It turns out that that will
generate for you a series that
is inverse powers of log z.
And in fact, inverse
even powers of log z.
So that the next term will fall
off as 1 over log z squared.
The next term will fall off
as 1 over z to the fourth
and so forth.
And the coefficient of
the first one-- and I
show you this in the notes,
how to calculate it--
is pi squared over
6 times m m minus 1.
The coefficient of
the next term is
7 pi to the fourth 360 m m
minus 1, m minus 2, m minus 3.
And there's a formula
for subsequent terms
in the series, how
they are generated.
And this thing is known as
the Sommerfeld expansion.
OK?
So, essentially, if you
plot as a function of z one
of these fm minuses of
z's, what we have according
to the previous
expansion, as you go to z
equals to 0 you have
a linear function z.
And then the next correction
is minus z squared.
You start to bend
in this direction.
And then you have higher
order corrections.
What we see, that at larger
values, it keeps growing.
And the growth at
larger values is this.
So here you have z minus z
squared 2 to the power of m.
Out here you have log z
to the m over m factorial.
And then this corrections
from the Sommerfeld expansion.
OK?
And so once we
have that function,
which is the right hand
side of this equality,
for a particular density we are
asking, what is the value of z?
And at low densities we are
evaluating solutions here.
At high values of
density we are picking up
solutions on this other.
OK?
So let's imagine that we
are indeed in that limit.
So what do we have?
We have that n lambda
cubed over g is log z
to the 3/2 over 3/2 factorial.
That's the leading term.
Sub-leading term is 1
plus pi squared over 6.
m, in our case, is 3/2.
m minus 1 would be 1/2
divided by log z squared.
I will stop at this order.
That's all we will need.
And so I will use this to
calculate z as a function n.
Again, same procedure as before.
I can invert this
and write this as log
z being 3/2 factorial
n lambda cubed over g.
so I multiplied by this.
I have to raise to the 2/3
power-- the inverse of 3/2.
I take this combination
to the other side.
So I have 1.
This becomes plus pi
squared over 8 1 over log z
squared raised to
the minus 2/3 power
because I had to take
it to the other side.
OK.
So at the lowest order,
what I need to do
is to calculate log z from the
zeroed order term and then,
at the next order, substitute
that value of log z in here
and get the next correction.
So the lowest order correction
will tell me that log z---
which, remind you,
is simply beta mu--
is this combination
raised to the 2/3 power.
What is that communication?
3/2 factorial.
3/2 factorial we saw
was 3/2 1/2 factorial--
which was root pi over 2--
so this is 3/2 factorial.
I have n over g.
Oh, sorry. n lambda cubed.
So write it in this
fashion. n over g.
And then I have lambda cubed.
Let me put this to the 2/3
power because lambda cubed
to the 2/3 power is
simply lambda squared.
And lambda squared is
going to be h squared
divided by 2 pi mkT.
So this is lambda cubed.
What I'm going to do
is notice that one
of these h over 2pi's is
in fact already an h bar.
I'd like to write
the result in terms
of h bar squared divided by 2m.
The 1 over kT I
can write as beta.
Ultimately, it is my intention
to cancel that beta which
is the 1 over kT in the
beta that I have out here.
And I get the value for mu.
OK?
To go from h squared over
2pi to h bar squared over 2m,
I need a factor of 4pi squared.
Those 4pi squared I will
put out front in here.
And they will change the result
to something that is like this.
It is n over g is going
to be remaining there.
I have pi by the time it
gets in front over here
becomes pi to the 3/2.
Pi to the 3/2 multiplied by pi
to the 1/2 becomes pi squared.
You can convince yourself
that the factors of 2
and all of those things
manage to give you
something that is 6pi squared
n over g to the 2/3 power.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when [INAUDIBLE]
chemical potential
as no temperature [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
When you go to 0 temperature,
the chemical potential
of a Fermi gas
goes to a constant
that you have actually
seen-- and I just
was about to make it clear
to you what that constant is.
So we get that limit as
essentially this T goes
to 0, which is another way of
achieving the combination n
lambda cubed over
g goes to infinity.
When T goes to 0,
lambda goes to infinity,
this combination becomes large.
Canceling the betas,
the limit of mu
is something that potentially
in solid state courses
you have seen as
the fermion energy.
And the fermion energy
is h bar squared over 2m.
Some Fermi momentum squared.
And hopefully the
Fermi momentum is
going to come out to be 6pi
squared n over g to the 1/3.
And one way that you usually
get your Fermi momentum is
you say that, what
I need to do is
to fill up all of this state
up to some value of kf.
And the number of
states that there are
is the volume of the
sphere- 4pi over 3k
f cubed, of course times the
volume times the degeneracy
coming from spins if I have
multiple possibilities.
And this should give
me the total number n.
Ah.
I made some big mistake here.
Can somebody point it out to me?
How do we calculate Fermi
momentum and Fermi [INAUDIBLE]?
Not coming out
the answer I want.
AUDIENCE: One [INAUDIBLE]
is a sphere, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's a sphere.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Divide by density of state.
I multiplied by the V but I
forgot the 2pi cubed here.
OK?
So when you divide 4pi
divided by 8pi cubed,
you will have 2pi
squared times 3,
which will give you 6pi squared.
n over V is the density.
Divided by g.
So you can see that we
get the right result.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] cubed.
PROFESSOR: f cubed.
Yes.
That's right.
So kf is 1/3 of that.
Let's go step by step.
A is 6pi squared n
over g to the 1/3.
kf squared would be the
2/3 power [? of g. ?] Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you said that
this is the lowest order
term for the chemical potential.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But aren't there
going to be maybe a second order
temperature dependent term?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So when we substitute
that formula in here,
we will find the value of
the chemical potential.
So I will draw it
for you and then
recalculate the result later.
So this is the
chemical potential
of the Fermi system as a
function of its temperature.
What did we establish so far?
We established that
at zero temperature
it is in fact epsilon f.
We had established that
at high temperature--
this was the discussion
we had before-- it's
large and negative.
It is down here.
So indeed the behavior
of the chemical potential
of the Fermi gas as a
function of temperature
is something like this.
And so the chemical potential at
zero temperature is epsilon f.
As you go to finite temperature,
it will get reduced by a factor
that I will just calculate.
OK?
So if I now substitute
this result in here
to get the next
correction, what do I have?
OK.
So this zero to order
term we established
is the same thing
as beta epsilon f.
And then the next order term
will be 1 plus-- this log
z is going to be small--
minus 2/3 times this
is going to give me
minus pi squared over 6.
Right?
And then I have 1
over log z squared.
One over log z is simply
1 over beta epsilon f
which is the same thing as
kT over epsilon f squared So
what we see is that the
chemical potential starts
to be epsilon f and then it
starts to go down parabolically
in temperature.
And the first correction is of
the order of kT over epsilon f.
Not surprisingly,
it will go to 0
at the value T that is off the
order of epsilon f over kT.
So the chemical potential
of the Fermi gas
actually changes sign.
It's negative and large
at high temperature,
it goes to the
Fermi energy which
is positive at low temperatures.
So once we know this behavior
or the chemical potential,
we can calculate what the
energy and pressure on.
And again, at zero
temperature you
will have some energy which
comes from filling out
this Fermi C. And then we
will get corrections to energy
and pressure that
we can calculate
using the types of
formulas that we have that
relate pressure and
energy to f 5/2 of z.
And so we can start to
calculate the corrections
that you have to
completely Fermi sphere.
And how those
corrections give you,
say, the linear heat
capacity is something
that we will derive next time.